Liz truss was forced to act by a crisis
of economic confidence in her and her
now ex-chancellor quasi quaten's plans
for the public finances this is how the
office for Budget responsibility said
things looked before the mini budget it
shows national debt as a share of GDP
you can see its forecast to fall over
the next five years that told markets
that in due course the UK would pay its
own way but this is what the mini budget
did to that calculation it slapped 45
billion pounds of unfunded tax cuts plus
the energy bailout and other costs on
top and the institute for fiscal studies
calculates that has left a 62 billion
pound hole that needs to be filled a
huge gap for new Chancellor Jeremy Hunt
to have to close to the satisfaction of
the markets the obr not to mention
conservative MPS now the u-turn on
corporation tax has closed the Gap by 19
billion pounds and the 45p rate cut
worth 2 billion that's already been
ditched but that still leaves a gap of
of 41 billion pounds now the National
Insurance cup which is staying accounts
for 18 billion pounds of that and other
Cuts including to the basic rate of
income tax and duty-free add another 6
billion but even if all those tax cuts
were reversed it doesn't fill the hole
and Liz truss has signaled that public
spending cuts are coming as yet the
markets are unconvinced this is what's
happened to 30-year bond yields that's a
measure of the cost of government
borrowing in this case the rule of thumb
is if the line goes up it's bad and down
is good and you can see that pressure
was Rising early in the week it's higher
at one point than after the mini budget
but it fell on speculation of a U-turn
and again on news quasi-quartang was
flying home from Washington but before
and after Liz truss's speech yields rose
that is bad news for government and all
of those worrying about their mortgages
now since the mini budget the bank of
England has been trying to prop up that
market and prevent a run on Pension
funds by buying guilts so that scheme
ended today the bank spent 19 billion
pounds in total of a possible 65 billion
it had set aside creating a deadline
that helped perhaps dictate political
events fingers will now be crossed at
the bank and the treasury that these
steps have been enough to restore
Financial stability whatever the cost to
the prime minister's political
credibility